hatten armee zu tun beides buchstaben
nein lassen ich wäre nicht schlecht der
war echt nicht schlecht
der fall schlechter geht nicht da und
seien herzlich willkommen zu einem
weiteren teil des mega projekts immer
noch in der chili mega aufnahme mit
kräfte endlich mal mit der er
geschrieben wohlgemerkt konkreter
sega hat mein mining glazer lädt sich
auch nicht auf fertig gepackt der name
mann ich bin voll liebe aktiv ich muss
irgendwas jetzt machen eigentlich muss
jetzt irgendwie raus gehen und in der
runde laufen und ich will hier spiele
wieder einfach grad nur lang scanne die
landschaft den fußboden und hoffe dass
wir irgendwann einen wert über 80 ploppt
und wenn ja dann bin ich am start und
runter bin ich am start
moin moin warf geht mein kopf nachteile
so heißt es bei mir und jetzt klopft
mein kopf ich muss eigentlich ich kann
das ja mal ganz kurz ich geh mal ganz
kurz runter
einzelspieler kurzem eine welt im eine
creative welt das seht ihr jetzt mal was
ich mir solche gedanken mache ja das
kommt alles noch jahr mache ich sofort
es denke nicht dass ich mich mit nicht
beschäftige also das soll nach schnauze
beim finale verteidigen so und zwar
wollte ich zu meinem haus bauen
eichenholz bretter sind das einfach
und das sind bestimmt denise
man kann nicht einfach
ich kann losgehen nicht aufladen hier
basalt break wieso nicht okay
okay weil es mich erstmal um die basalt
briggs kümmern
dann ist ja kaká wahrscheinlich geht das
nur ein fkk basalt kumpels wieder
zurücklaufen
wir haben noch nie gesehen dass hier das
sagen hier das lässt sich noch aus wie
mache ich mir bei sollten briggs heiko
blocher mit basalt cobblestone ich gucke
noch welches nur mit basalt wirklich nur
was alt cobblestone verbrennen so so so
und dann lade ich wieder auf zack zack
sagt die unnötig das ist erstmal
verbrennen muss er
ich sage ich schon
vom land verbrannt sind
ich brauche holz deswegen nehme ich mir
jetzt meine chainsaw ein chart meister
nämlich mit lade meine chain store auf
und fliegt los
jetzt heißt es wieder ballern werden
mad pack ist quasi einfach nur so ein
ding was energie speichert was du damit
nehmen können oder kann sich halt
aufladen über den solar hin
ja da mache ich doch dann setzen wir das
so erzielt dann hoffe ich euro simon hat
mir geschrieben glaube ich hoffe ich
habe viel geschrieben sie mal extra
diamanten gefahren hat heute abend zeit
nee ich hab aber keine zeit bin ich weg
komm jetzt geben
eine folge nehme gerade mit scaf auslese
diesen chat verlauf gerade in der
aufnahme vor cous cous pigs crafter mir
geschrieben und
eine pvp äpfel die wir planen ganz
ehrlich
die diamanten in tirol an ich finde jede
scheiße aber keine diamanten wirklich
alles alles alles da obst ist immer aus
dem haus das würde an der chain sodass
sie hat relativ schnell halt alle geht
dann hab ich schon so was von bugs
einfach mit dass geiseln meinen laser
kann ich obwohl 12 eigentlich zum mega
tunnel bauen
aber das habe ich schon volk schon gerne
im baumhaus wie simon
ich glaube jetzt auch gern richtig penis
fast aber nicht beides buchstaben nein
weiß nicht wer war nicht schlecht der
war echt nicht schlecht darauf mal
schlecht was schlecht ist einfach alles
was flach ist außerdem leidet im bereich
vor
der meister der flachen witzen alles was
fleisch ist es bei kalter denke ich gut
kann da wo wir wissen doch freude wohl
am anfang werde abgebaut haben das sieht
übels geil jetzt aus so baut werde mit
stil ab nicht nur kaffee getrunken ich
habe viel und person
ein schuss mache ich noch aber war sich
aber auch wo man ausgang da so hey was
hast du gut gemacht
100 franken gewesen diamanten gefahr
aber jetzt wieder raus und was hast du
zuschüsse gemacht dann mit einem laser
so walla mit meinem laserdom ich schieße
mit meinem langen laser wie weit kannst
damit abbauen und ein schuss baut 10
wirkte vor die ab das heißt ich laufe
einfach nur bam bam bam bam nummer ich
sind zwei mal zwei tunnel bis ich
irgendwann diaz findet das ist gut aber
ich habe keinen hass gefunden also ich
habe sechs ist vielleicht auch das ding
ist ich fahre ja die angst weil ich mir
anschaue oder machen und bmf in rosegg
entscheidern du bist direkt neben dem
spawn das läuft auch so die ganze zeit
weiter wirklich ja so weil du direkt in
dem spot on ist relevant weil ich tue
ja weil es born ist ja nur das motto
wenn da keiner ist richtig die jena hat
was geschrieben sein meinte aber zu mir
das wenn man das ordentlich die zweite
chance drumherum auf glaube ich weil
sonst ist ein junkie oder schwer zu
machen
nein aber nur verteidigt und dann also
doch nur diamanten halten
jetzt hab ich ja welche gefahren es ist
nicht mehr allzu schwer sein
doch
mal die ganze größe weg sowie können wir
gleich noch mal kämen jetzt bin jetzt
just in diesem moment also jetzt gibst
du schon im bett geht nicht geniess aber
nicht schlecht das war die waffe der
wahl mich lässt er sich zum bett geht
nicht dass ein autokrat übrigens habe
ich hier die falschen robust einfach
richtig aus im hausbau
ich versuche mal hier so am ende so mein
haus ein bisschen weiter zu haben so
also das erscheint zu laufen hier haben
wir alles wie folgt ein energiespeicher
ist fast leer
ja ok liegt so wirklich jetzt ja in
diesem moment liege ich gerade im bett
houston die so weit bin ich aufgewacht
weil ich hoffe energie kommen
warum war es da dass er eine freud nicht
das tue ich auch erst mal weg das bereue
ich nicht den scanner der laser kommt
weg wie bereite ich der falsche weg war
hat sich das volk jahre pauli aus zuerst
mal abgeräumt
meine query hat bestimmt schon einen
ganzen ein ganzes grundstück oder
ausgefüllt wenn ihr curry gebaut wie
mein ganzes stück ausfüllt ich dachte
gerade so ich hatte mein jetpack so mmb
drin machst du einmal rechtzeitig 2 ich
verkaufe ein bug jetpack
glaub mein hund gekommen
ich hab mal überlegt was man aus kappel
stone machen kann ich meine irgendwas
muss ja mit dem mit dem minimum scherbe
möglich sein
ich habe meine guckt man kann sich gras
machen und feuerstein sich feuerstein
aus der mini um scherbe machen mit kabel
soll aus einem feuerstein und mini um
scherbe kannst du dir leben machen
ich brauch leben ausleben und mini um
stein kannst du dir hier kannst du dir
als du musst dich zu einem im leben
waren zusammen also die vier den
gesamtsieg mal wie mache ich mir leben
oder halten kann so ausleben
du kannst du dann auszugehen und gemini
um stein eisen kräften sei es doktor ich
zu ihr wenn wir zu wenig zugehört und
ich kann ihm aus kreisen machen
im endeffekt und ich habe ungefähr 200
ex alter ganz normale wechsel hatten
jetzt nicht so stur ein auto zuerst ich
will erst mal selber bauen
ich habe gefragt ob du leben hast für
mich ich habe gesagt man kann mit dem
mini um stein und kabel zusammenleben
machen so dass man das machen
das ding ist weißt du wie das mit den
pipes funktioniert also ich weiß alles
wie es mit dem ipad funktioniert nur
automatische workbench ist nicht weißt
du was du musst ein rezept reinlegen
niemand ein rezept bei dem architektur
tischer noch niemand
wenn die alten kumpel zum automatischen
workbench geleitet werden musst du da
die items angeordnet haben einmal dann
werden wir aber drauf automatische
workbench es heißt ich punkte da rein
und wo muss ich dir ein pumpen
womit wird gepaart mit eu oder mit
vorweisen nicht weil ich bisher nur
einem video gesehen alles klar war das
ding vermutlich richtig viel energie
kosten und immer echt gespannt ich muss
mich hier wie gesagt nächstes ziel
freunde
ich baue mir jetzt wie so eine mega
maschinerien und daraus mal am endeffekt
dass ich mir aus kappel stone über den
ganzen weg glichkeit eben schnell
erklärt habe dass ich mir eisen machen
und ich meine dass später alles machen
seiner goldenen diamantenen habe ich ja
genug das habe ich mir schon gedacht
dass ich einfach so übel zu fahren mache
und dann halt krems ganz vieles
kommission habe noch die ganze nacht im
zimmer gelagert werden ich weiß nicht
genau wie das mit pipes genau
funktioniert ich hab's probiert haben
allerdings nicht so gut hingekriegt also
nicht ich kenn mich da relativ gut aus
er hat mir auch schon passiert versucht
oft habe ich versucht so eine diamanten
fabrik aus kavelstorf machen und zwar
indem ich kabel store und klein crash
irgendwie kies draus bekomme und dann
den kies noch mal in einem mega kracher
oder wie das auch wieder so fett ist
gegen das irgendwie dann muss auch
zweimal dreimal 2 also ein
das ist lukas ist keine ein blogger
maschine sondern so eine so eine mega
maschine den ganzen raum fast und die
kreisstadt irgendwie kies klein zusammen
und hat bei 1 prozentige chancen die
herauskommt da dachte ich mir gut wenn
ja wann endlich kies habe weil wie
kabels down dungey diene aber irgendwie
hat das gar nicht geklappt also wirklich
gar nichts klappt aber hier mit dem
stein ist das ja sicher
ja das muss mir da noch mal bei dir
angucken so die frage ist wo mache ich
das jetzt ich habe ja keinen platz und
ich brauche platz
ich brauche gerade dieses wird ich
brauche ja wirklich platz und es gibt
einmal robert zusammen geschrieben und
einmal auseinander
es ist komplett außer an das haus mit
bürste sind
sie sandten sieht anders aus ist eine
wächst man soll die riesigen bäumen das
andere halt soja anhalt diesem normalen
robert result geht jetzt hier einfach
mal einen tunnel reinbauen und bisschen
ausholen und hoffen dass laser holen das
geht so gar nicht diese zwei drei mal
mit meinem dicken laser und dann ein
loch in der wand schießt zweimal mit
seinem dicken laser als an loch 9
überrollte für energie darüber lacht er
nicht aber wenn ich sage ich kann nicht
darüber lacht